so schools as we just told you are
reopening
in the country's biggest city new york
but many businesses are facing new
coronavirus restrictions
this week including bans on indoor
dining
in response to this total economic
destruction
of an entire sector of the economy one
restaurant in the borough of staten
island
max public house has declared itself
quote an autonomous zone
a sign on the door of the restaurant
reads this way quote we refuse to abide
by any rules and regulations put forth
by the mayor of new york city
and the governor of new york state keith
mcelroy is the co-owner of that
restaurant max public house and he joins
us tonight keith
thanks so much for coming on so tell us
what made you decide to become your own
country
on staten island
basically what has taken place
is the the food industry and bar
industry we all end up wanting
to work with the government when we
decided that
they decided that we could start
reopening and they never came to
the professionals the ones that owned
the bars and the restaurants
and everything they never came to us to
end up asking how to do that in a safe
way
yeah basically all they did was dictate
to us what we're supposed to do
and with doing that you still weren't
able to survive
so it brought us to a point that they're
saying that they were shutting us down
again
that they weren't allowing inside dining
and
i was put against the wall it's either i
took a stance and ended up opening my
continue to keep my establishment open
hoping that people end up coming to
spend money so i can pay bills
and end up providing for my family i'm
so behind on bills
that i've i've really felt i had no
other choice
and i was with doing this it was to
to tell the governor and to tell the
mayor that
you need to work with us but you didn't
want to work with us
and we're forced into this situation
that i don't know what else i can do
yeah
well i feel for you turns out your white
privilege isn't paying the bills
automatically
um you're coming on the show you're
taking a stand
you're clearly going to enrage the
people in charge of new york city and
new york state are you worried they're
going to come after you
are coming after me already i i already
had the state liquor authority
um we caught the the radar of the the
mayor
right away um the sheriffs came out
and uh as a bully tactic
to fine us and they were very
professional the sheriffs
but at the same time they were coming on
the orders of uh
of the mayor because of the fact that i
was
remaining open and still remaining open
past 10 o'clock
it brought the attention of the other
agencies out there
and um you know they're they're they're
coming after me
your tax dollars at work well you're a
brave man and we wish you godspeed
and i hope you'll come back and tell us
how it goes keith thanks so much
thank you very much